In this problem, a given wastewater
treatment plant is being upgraded. A new
screw pump is being added which will
handle an additional 10 million gallons
per day during wet weather and be used
to control the depth of water in the wet
well. The wet well is 20 ft deep. The
average daily flow at the treatment
plant is 10 mgd and the required
chlorine demand is 50 lb per hour. This
is achieved by two chlorinator units
each with a max dosing rate of 10 mg per
liter as
Cl2 currently dosing a combined
concentration of 7 mg per liter into
this flow.
If a mass of,200 lb of chlorine is used
per day during
disinfection, find the daily peaking
factor that was used in the current
operation of this treatment
plant. So this problem has a very long
problem
statement. However, all it is asking us
to find is the peaking factor that
accompanies a certain concentration of
chlorine. Some of you may already
recognize how to solve this problem. For
those of you who might not, on this
question, I tried to be helpful and
include the phrase mass per day in the
problem
statement. I realize it's vague, but if
you happen to search for this, it would
take you to the correct section in the
manual with the following equation.
If you go to section
6.7.1 mass conservation and
continuity there is a section called the
concentration to mass per day
conversion. Here it gives us the exact
equation that we need to solve this
problem.
It's given as mass
m in units of pounds per
day equals a
concentration C in units of mg per
liter times Q which is our
flow in units of MGD.
times our conversion of
8.34. And the units for this is going to
be
pounds per million
gallons
over mg per liter.
So once we know what equation to use, we
can see that this question is actually
extremely simple to solve and that only
a small subset of the information given
in the problem is
required. We don't need anything about
the screw
pump, the wet
well or the max dosing rates of the two
chlorinator units.
We don't even necessarily need the
information about the chlorine demand in
pounds per hour since we are given the
chlorine demand in pounds per
day. All this problem requires is that
you understand two
things. How to convert pounds per day to
milligrams per liter which is going to
be given by the reference manual
here. And knowing that total flow is
going to be the average daily flow times
the peaking factor. So let's include
peaking factor into this equation as
well. Now that this equation is set up,
we can solve it
directly.
Our pounds per day of chlorine mass is
already given as
1,200. Our concentration of chlorine is
given as 7 mg per
liter. Our flow here is going to be
given
as the average daily flow of 10 million
gallons per day.
We are looking for our peing
factor and we have our
conversion. If we simplify this down and
solve for the peaking
factor, we can see that our final answer
is very close to two.
which is our second answer over
here. So, this problem is intentionally
meant to take a while to read and
requires you to pick out exactly what
information is needed to solve the
problem. If you can get through that
part, all this is is a simple conversion
of pounds per day to milligrams per
liter at a given flow rate with a known
conversion factor.
And that's it.